it's one of the most instantly
recognizable cars on the planet and the
new Porsche 911 Turbo S is due to hit
the road at the end of the year its
makers have somehow managed to further
enhance the souped-up speedster Porsche
has moved from the active to adaptive
aerodynamics explains Thomas vegan
instead of the straightforward rear wing
still seen in the 997 Turbo there's a
rear wing and a retractable rear spoiler
the changes were always necessary
because of the 911s less-than-ideal
aerodynamics the body's teardrop shape
resembles that of an airplane wing
differing air flows on the upper and
lower sides result in the up force that
lifts planes off the ground
to prevent this happening with the 911
Porsche added parts to keep the car fast
but firmly on the road the car maker
continues to use rigid systems with some
models the retractable rear wing that is
graced the 911 turbo for so many years
has now been revamped and now moves in
two stages and it's angle changes
according to whether the sunroof is open
or not opening the sunroof completely
changes the cars aerodynamics explains
bad Hammond
the wing can be adjusted to keep the
vehicle balanced among the all new
features is the pneumatically extendable
three-stage front spoiler it generates
additional downforce on the front axle
stephane Herzl reveals that the first
time within 99 1 turbo Porsche used a
mobile spoiler that can move to
different positions in the start
position and has a much higher approach
angle compared to the preceding model
which makes it easier to enter parking
garages in the performance setting the
downforce can rival that seen in
Motorsports the front edge is far lower
down and it's extended forward a little
to reach maximum downforce the
intermediate speed setting which is
engaged automatically at 120 km/h is set
for optimum efficiency which means
downforce values and drag coefficients
similar to those in our preceding model
the 997 Turbo but when combining
adjustable spoiler and wing it's crucial
that they are correctly coordinated
otherwise the aerodynamics could in fact
worsen we realigned a car to test this
so that we could steer the rear wing
with the front spoiler extended coming
up on the left the standard
configuration and on the right the test
setup
the misalignment causes chaos on the
rear axle and the car drifts out
so assuming the setup is correct
the faster you drive the greater the
downforce will be in other words speed
means safety of course not says Thomas
vegan the aerodynamic forces are
proportional to the speed squared and
the steering response is far more
sensitive these effects compensate each
other a steering movement at a higher
speed will be compensated by the higher
aerodynamic forces so you're equally
safe whatever the speed